[موسيقى]
وبوسعنا هنا التحدث عن الامارات كمثال اذ
بدانا بمكتب تمثيل لمجموعه من مسؤول
المبيعات في ابوظبي ومن ثم كانت الخطوه
التاليه عبر اقامه شركه مع شريك اماراتي
محلي وقبل سنوات اتخذنا خطوه اضافيه
بافتتاح شركه اجنبيه على ارض الامارات
نقوم من خلالها بالاعمال الهندسيه وتطوير
المنتجات وتجهيز المصانع واعدادها ومن ثم
تقديم الدعم على المستوى الاقليمي
[موسيقى]
كما ان المنتجات التي نقوم بتطويرها هنا
هي جزء من المحفظه الكامله لساب وكذلك على
صعيد السوق العالميه هذه واحد من الطرق
التي نتبعها لتوسيعتها حصتنا من السوق
الاقليميه
[موسيقى]
نسعى للتقارب مع القطاع الاكاديمي واقامه
علاقات شراكه مع شركات مثيره في المنطقه
ولتحقيق ذلك بنجاح نحتاج لوجود شركه ثابته
لنا في المنطقه هذه هي حقيقه استراتيجيتنا
من اجل زياده حصتنا في اسواق الشرق الاوسط
[موسيقى]